hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to it moves an RPG horror
game that touts a very good story so I'm
gonna try to play through the whole game
in one now I did read some comments
hello in the last video that were saying
that my webcam was a bit too bright so I
got a different setup hopefully it's a
bit more ominous for you bedtime bedtime
is supposed to be a happy event for a
tired child for me it was terrifying
while some children might complain about
being put to bed before they have
finished watching a film or playing
their favorite video game when I was a
child
nighttime was something to truly fear
somewhere in the back of my mind it
still is how I was like these this is me
my child or am i adult right now I can
move mr. Teddy I was just playing a game
with a mr. teddy how are you doing it's
a wolf
very good full of toys and stuff poster
from a movie I got it from my brother
now I don't know if this is actually
made on RPG horror maker or RPG maker in
ace I don't remember what the current
version is but it looks quite different
as someone who's trained in the
scientists cannot prove that what
happened to me was objectively real but
I can swear that what I experienced was
genuine horror a fear which in my life
I'm glad to say has never been equaled I
will relate it to you all now as best I
can make of it what you will but I'll be
glad to just get it off my chest you got
it buddy are you a kid right now I'm
just gonna assume is this your puppy
this is my father okay that's all you
have to say to your father
shoes not very interesting I'll be the
judge of what is and is not interesting
flowers mom put thee there hi did
anybody just notice that this kid's
voice is very deep this is my brother's
room he told me yesterday to keep out of
the room that we both had shared until
then oh why cuz he just hit puberty and
he needs some alone time
mama I can't remember exactly when it
started but my apprehension towards
falling asleep seemed to correspond with
my being moved into a room of my own
well thanks a lot bro are you my mother
okay nothing to say to her either
nothing too interesting oh maybe I need
to talk to him again
how do you like your new room zoom
you'll be sleeping alone for the first
time yes I seemed very good mama
mom told me not to touch her stuff
especially this stuff why what kind of
stuff does mama have over there oh look
it's Ron Burgundy from anchorman anybody
know just a bunch of clothes in here
ventilation I think mom said this is oh
my boxes full of stuff so apparently the
whole family's moving and I need to go
talk to Papa I was eight years old at
the time and until then I had shared a
room quite happily with my older brother
as soon as is perfectly understandable
for a boy five years my senior my
brother was eventually wished for a room
of his own and as a result I was given
the room in the back of the house as my
brother was given a new bed I was given
the bunk beds with we used to share
while I was except about sab said about
sleeping on my own I was excited at the
thought of being able to sleep in the
top bunk which seemed far more
adventurous to me you are a very boring
kid don't go pulling out too much stuff
now it's bedtime soon so should I go to
sleep should I go to sleep it's locked
stupid bro hi come on I'm your little
bro you're supposed to love me
unconditionally
I get the baby Oh baby
Haemon we're all wasn't doing anything
all right as bedtime already
yes adults need their sleep you see
you'll be sleeping alone for the first
time you excited yes mom I'm also
terrified what are you gonna do to me
what'll happen to me 99 mom all right
I'm turning off the lights good night
there's no monsters under your bed or in
your closet or right behind you
don't turn around just then it'll get
really mad okay
good night oh boy hello darkness my old
friend here we meet each other again
that's not how the song goes but I was
encoding the song Seve okay I'm in a
forest that's perfectly normal
why was that thing is that the thing
from they breathe that was a good game
by the way No oh I'm playing I didn't
even notice myself down there
hello old wise frog man you gotta help
me
I seem to be lost a small waterhole the
water is dirty probably not a good idea
to drink it well kid at least you're
smarter than a lot of kids I see in
horror games they'll just jump right in
or drink whatever is put in front of
them okay not a good idea to drink from
it don't mind the strange wouldn't greet
wooohooo woodland creatures that are
everywhere okay in the house why not oh
good a skull door that's normal a pot
and some ragged cloth why I wonder
what's cooking brains human brains
or you know chicken or something anybody
that's a face yeah like that's there's a
face stalking is such a strong word I
prefer to think of it as more intense
research on one individual that is a
face the Frick frakkin face by the way
my missing sock is under your bed with
me okay
King haha let's I'll go let me stay here
for a little bit I just found a new
friend giant face man
the window hall you just gotta say the
same thing okay let go down we're gonna
die this is where I die weird mushroom
looks poisonous let's eat it
what is that scent you big dude face man
okay there's something back there enough
weird mushroom looks play suppose I saw
the glowy glow on the wall but I don't
know if that's what it was pointing me
towards did you need something mr. face
man he's gone
oh no whatever am I gonna do I don't
know ooh I like this I don't often get
to say that you know I've been enjoying
games more I mean I always enjoy the
games I play except for some of them
here and there but I always like a story
that can get me involved
mr. face man is that you and honestly I
have no idea what's going on here red
liquid seeping out from the mushroom hat
it's a mushroom hat eh I'll need that
for my team fortress do character need
to get all of them I actually stopped
playing tf2 a while ago I used to play
it every single day for hours and oddly
enough I wouldn't play it online that
much I just play against bots it was a
perfect stress reliever
what's with the glowy glow on the walls
why are they there why is anything here
I do have to say this Luke's room
who's that those are face whose two
faces
I think I saw a block of face are you
doing over there you got a special
surprise for me something is it my
birthday already ma'am
all puzzles huh oh okay so I need to
find out how to beat the puzzle oh I see
so these puzzles raise the blocks in
certain okay I'm done a geek I guess we
know it's done
oh no they need to be down okay I got it
they were already done I had already
beaten it sorry I'm just too smart for
my own good thank you everybody for
believing in me in that incredibly
difficult puzzle Oh
something weird is happening here and I
don't much care for it where am I
supposed to go oh I was just supposed to
go to the right I'm just trying to make
sure that I don't miss anything because
it's very dark mr. Mays man thought you
so pretty what have you done the face of
BOE up in this [ __ ] Yauch biznatch
hi mr. face man are you my only friend
in this place why do you sound like a
morphogenetic ain Julian Angley in okay
goodbye goodbye I'm just gonna go walk
across this narrow shaking bridge
nothing bad happened to me has okay
rumbling roars in the background I'm
gonna be perfectly fine I wonder how my
brother and family are doing
I miss em so dearly hogs of a spider but
the spider face
run-run okay I'm dad also dad good good
I'm glad that happened ah
what oh god happy chirping birds Oh mom
ma'am I had a bad dream mom
oh I'm not out of the dream yet mi mah
mah mah mah mah mum mum mah mah wake up
I'm gonna balance on your bellies till
you wake up Moll I had a bad dream
ma ma mom mom sweetie what's wrong I had
a bad dream oh that's too bad
that's too bad sweetie I'll be up in a
minute we can eat breakfast together
alright hurry up hurry up mom go change
your clothes and I'll be right there I'm
one of those bratty kids that bugs their
mom in the grocery store dad you need to
learn your English a little better okay
no need to go here right now what about
my bro bro bro had a bad dream no I'm
not a stupid bro
we gotta be so mean me I shouldn't go
outside right now what does that mean am
I gonna go back to bed well I can't move
oh I needed to change my clothes that's
right I forgot and so another day
started it was a little day of little
importance to our story I won't bother
you with the details the one thing I
remember is that even though I played
with friends like I always did I somehow
still felt lonely I didn't enter my new
room until later that night it was time
to go to sleep again Oh God
ugh dying green arrow pointing me where
I'm so as if I didn't know already enter
nightmare land nice pajamas those are a
lot like the among the sleep baby's
pajamas all blue and star speckled is
anybody there
are you under my bed with a sock mister
face spider
they spider-man yes I will save thank
you
whoa what do we have here Oh red button
that goes burn this reminds me of
something what was that one a game that
I played lone survivor that was a really
fun game it reminds me of the hotels in
there
man happy smile so that was a happy okay
am I supposed to push him in a certain
order I'm guessing well that one was a
happy nope okay process of elimination
means that I need to go down here oh
they're all happy
oh they're happy when I need to press
him wait no oh well I got it right
anyway so whatever they didn't paint it
oh goody goody gumdrops now I can go
home to my family and never have to live
this nightmare ever again except I do
over and over again I'm kind of
machinery yeah what is that
why is there a gurgling sound not that I
don't trust the normal gurgling sounds
Anna Corp gurgling sounds that I hear in
my day-to-day existence hi are you doing
there hi what are you doing there
feel like I'm repeating myself what are
is going on what are s going on what am
I supposed to do here wait did I get
okay I was thought I got trapped in
there for a second okay so I'm just
gonna try to do a house I'll take that
mean other did I just see something or I
might am I fooling myself I might whoa
that was so like there are things in the
walls or something bad hey god damn it
Jesus scared the bejesus out of me huh
you stay away you are actually something
like this I thought I was alone
sometimes wanted poster I thought being
alone was bad but apparently being in a
hall full of monsters is even worse got
something going on here some sort of
concert
of Boquete not gonna jump out of me that
time good cuz if you had I would have
socked you in the face of my own I just
need to know if I need to run away
really quickly
hello nothing of interest I think it
looks like a patch of skin on the wall
yeah boring who needs to know okay hi my
friend
which way am i said am i getting faster
did I just get a lot faster I seem to be
so much faster why am i so much faster
did I get speed boost from being
touching those little legs I see a
little red thing come on
so fast I'm like Sonic I gotta go fast
instructions on how to use a fire
extinguishers that'll be value why is it
getting more intense no no no no no no
no no no no no no hello can I have you
how many more do I need how many more do
I need
how many more where am I going what am i
doing okay I've already been here but I
haven't been all the way down here I
think I loop through this way went down
here over here up here I think it come
to every corner of the place maybe I
haven't maybe I you come on so finicky
no I've already been up there so maybe
if I go this way no this just leads back
to the hallway oh god the sounds the
sounds are getting me it sounds a really
putting me on edge well thank you was
that why is there a gurgling grumbly oh
god there's a face on my screen I just
noticed that there's a face there's a
face on my screen that's not just me
right that's just something behind me
I'm not going crazy there was a little
in legitimate face on my green
it's getting bigger Oh God hello hi
you took me somewhere fun okay you
waking from a deep sleep to something
moving or stirring it could take a few
moments for you to truly understand what
is happening the fog of sleep hangs over
your eyes and ears even when lucid
something was moving it was no doubt
about that at first I wasn't sure what
it was everything was dark almost
pitch-black but there was enough light
creeping in from outside to outline that
room
two thoughts appeared in my mind almost
simultaneously the first was that my
parents were in bed because the rest of
the house laid both in darkness and
silence the second thought turned to the
noise a noise which had obviously woken
me Jesus that was it bed sheets rustling
in the dark and someone breathing as if
some disturbed sleeper was attempting to
get all too comfortable in the bottom
bunk I lay there and disbelief thinking
that the noise with either my
imagination or perhaps just my pet cat
finding somewhere comfortable to spend
the night it was then that I noticed my
door shut as it had been when I'd fallen
asleep
perhaps my mom had checked in on me and
the cat it sneaked into my room then yes
that must have been it I turned to face
the wall closing my eyes in the vain
hope that I could fall back to sleep as
I moved the rustling noise from
underneath me ceased I thought that I
must have disturbed my cat but quickly I
realized that the visitor in the bottom
bunk was much less mundane than my pet
trying to sleep and much more sinister
as if alerted to and disgruntled by my
presence the disturbed sleeper began to
toss and turn violently like a child
having a tantrum in their bed I could
hear the sheets twist and turn with
increasing ferocity fear then gripped me
not like the subtle sense of unease I
had experienced earlier but now potent
and terrifying my heart raced as my eyes
panicked scanning the almost
impenetrable darkness I let out a cry as
most young boys do I instinctively
shouted on my mother I could hear
something stir on the other side of the
house but as I began to breathe a sigh
of relief that my parents were coming to
save me the bunk bed suddenly started to
shake violently as if gripped by an
earthquake scraping against the wall I
could hear the sheets below me thrashing
around as if tormented by malice I did
not want to jump down to safety as I
feared the thing in the bottom bunk
would reach out and grab me pulling me
into darkness so I stayed there white
knuckles clenching my own blanket like a
shroud of protection
the weight seemed like an eternity
what's wrong
did you have a bad dream I cried and my
mother consoled me tears of fear
followed by relief streamed down my face
yet through all of the horror and relief
I did not tell her why I was so upset I
cannot explain it but it was as though
whatever had been in that bunk would
return if even so much as spoke of it
whether that was the truth I do not know
but as a child I felt as if that unseen
Menace remained close listening my
mother lay in the empty bunk promising
to stay there until morning
I remember the next day wanting to go
anywhere be anywhere but in that
suffocating room it was a Saturday and I
played outside quite happily with my
friends although our house was not large
we were lucky to have a long sloping
garden in the back we played there often
as much as it of it was overgrown and we
could hide in the bushes climb in the
house sycamore tree which towered above
all else and easily imagined ourselves
in the throes of a grand adventure as
fun as it all was occasionally my eye
would turn to that small window in my
room
ordinary slight and innocuous but for me
that thin boundary was a looking glass
into a strange cold pocket of dread
outside the lush green surroundings of
our garden filled with the smiling faces
of my friends inside the feeling of
something in that room watching me play
waiting for the night when I would be
alone eagerly filled with hate it may
sound strange to you but by the time my
parents assured me back into that room
for the night I said nothing
I didn't protest I didn't even make an
excuse as to why I couldn't sleep there
I still felt that this thing would be
enraged if I so much as spoke of it
another night came
okay y'all save good oh that's good man
that was like legit creepypasta level
I was trying that it's hard to read
something for the first time so I hope
you guys didn't mind me stumbling over
my words a few time I'm usually good
hello I'm usually good at reading things
right oh hi right off the bat but hope
you guys enjoyed that little bit of
narration something stirs in the
darkness it moves god that is creepy as
hell that was legitimately terrifying
god that gave me chills
hi okay oh good a pentagram the source
of all goodness oh wait was that
goodness I don't know hello what am I
supposed to do now what should I fetch
now that I'm in a nightmare land okay
but either way that was so cool guys you
got to admit I mean these RPG games or
RPG horror games are obviously very
story driven so it's really cool to see
one that really gets into the story and
if you were listening to me and not
really reading I stumbled over some
things it wasn't that typo II the
English in this one is pretty good I
don't know if there were some mistakes
but I apologize once again for making
any whoa I legitimately have I'm so
tense right now this is awesome oh man
I'm thoroughly enjoying myself on this
one no exaggeration about it and I have
no idea what I'm supposed to do I
haven't seen any clues yet wait a minute
is there something to this I haven't
seen anything yet cuz in the other one I
was collecting like weird red face dolls
of some live isn't character now I just
hear squeaky noises why aren't my
nightmares filled in such old-timey
machinery what is this a machine for
pigs okay so I'm assuming that I need to
find a way to unlock these gates which
means that probably one of them is gonna
be in Locke to begin with and these
weird rooms I don't know what I'm
supposed to do here if I'm supposed to
I did I couldn't press anything couldn't
interact just assuming one of these Bo
hi what is that what is that hello hi
how are you
are you a thing are you alive okay t go
toggle well I'm glad that did that thing
that that thing did I wonder what man is
suing nightmare Orlando I'm gonna hello
I can't tell if you're our face or if
you're trapped back there I can't tell
what you is I'm gonna go this way okay
so I'm gonna assume that unlock
something and now I need to go find
witch whoa hi hi there friend
hey how are you doing okay that's locked
this way goes to no wait a minute can I
get in there is that all all right cool
are you - I'm much older than - I think
I remember wait
are you I can't read that how are how
are you I'm fine thank you for asking me
you know it really means a lot that you
take the time out of your busy day to
ask me how I'm doing now I know that
there are bars behind this gate so I
need oh it was right there in front of
my face how could I not see that you
guys would have been very upset with me
if I had missed that okay but I'm smart
enough to know that if I'm dumb enough
to miss it I can backtrack a bit and
find my way once again okay so that's
barred up they're all barred up over
there it's gonna be a bit of
back-and-forth going to find where
exactly I need to go first
where do I need to go here we go yay
this is fun
Oh God way better than playing with my
childhood friends is way better than
having cherished memories of a
non-threatening nightmarish childhood I
would rather have this blood rust on the
walls rust and blood is perfectly fine
my favorite my favorite actually hello
found the next one good Nick
static haze under an okay I'm gonna go
now I'm gonna go now
hello what are you smiling so smiley a
really weird
Oh hurry bubs I would what about some
tight layaway
are you gonna kill me now you could kill
me you gonna kill me don't kill me I
don't want to die who'd rather live what
the hell was that supposed to be gay
that's so blocked up I've kind of
forgotten exactly where I've been before
I thought this one was blocked up before
noise
this one's oh hi what are you why are
you standing behind there why you be
weird okay I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
away now
I wanna go have fun elsewhere in
elsewhere land where I'm not bothered by
the likes of you like this at all I just
good I think I've said that already
God just give me the heebie-jeebies like
no other game has it really is often
hard for these games to do that cuz
they're low res and whatnot how many
have I activated I don't even know okay
so I think I accidentally backtracked
when I saw that that face I thought that
it might have killed me if I didn't get
back to where the middle pentagram or
something so I was a little worried
about that okay this one Kurt Junkers oh
good the rivers of blood have arrived
just a dime then next come the strippers
and then we're gonna have a grand old
time
goodbye rivers of blood I gotta find out
what you unlock yes
sure okay listen I'm good still good
thanks for asking I'm gonna go in
millions and millions oh good what is
that what is that about everybody a
blowout here hello friend are you good
ah God put it here wasn't there one
other one that was locked up over here
or was that the one that I just went
through I don't remember I remember
where I've been I think there's one to
the top right maybe was that I get that
already
Oh oh good this one one away I'd already
did that one already did it hmm I'm
gonna be stuck for the rest of my life
with a professional face of worry god
damn it come on I can get to you you're
not that scary
a lot of comments for this game actually
said that this game was scary without
relying on jump scares which I much
appreciate because a lot of games are
very - too liberal with the jump scare
in your face Ness so even though this
one has somewhat you would qualify as
jump scares god I'm going in as I don't
know where I'm going it's still God the
atmospheres so good all the rivers of
blood I remember you so I've already
gotten this one to the top right
definitely got that one it's the top
left maybe I didn't get I don't remember
where I am and have not been we're gonna
need to help me guys it's gonna be like
Blue's Clues
more like blues nightmares there's
something moving over there I thought I
saw something moving in the darkness but
I've already been there couldn't be
something can be couldn't be something
else here no this is the way lights are
playing tricks on my mind there must be
something to the top left that I've
overlooked because I think I've gone
everywhere but there Oh God you again
don't even try it
I'm immune I'm immune have I been here
no I have not okay cool that's where I
supposed to be what is that what is that
what is that what is that is that a box
it's that tiny box Tim it was a little
too girthy to be time everyone ignore
that that's weird that's I don't know
what that is hello kachunk what else
what else can you possibly do what else
can you possibly do could you go away
get out of here
get out of here I said get out of here
sorry about that I don't know what that
was all about that was weird
err okay so I need to go this way I
think the only one left is my friend
here oh he's still blocked up what other
one oh the bottom right bottom right
bottom right that's right bottom right
bottom right bottom right
I'm gonna be fine I'm gonna be good
I'm just a little kid wandering through
a land of nightmares what could possibly
go wrong already been here well okay
cool
yes yes yes yes yes yes I like it I like
it I got it okay so now that I got that
there's only one other place that could
possibly be gotten and that's my friend
over there with a weird jack-o'-lantern
head I really hope that I don't die
enough to do this and well know hover
wait what no yeah that's already been
gotten you can't fool me I'm not stupid
enough to fall for that again all right
where are you where are you are you over
there still there you still know you're
gone so I mean you're floating around
the world thank you nothing I just want
to go home to the pentagram I think that
was all last one I'm gonna go home I'm
gonna see my mom all gautam huh
pulsating red flesh faces why why mister
pulsating red flesh faces are you here
how do I get around you is there another
entrance that I need to take oh this is
all just gonna be a dead end how am I
supposed to get there what am I supposed
to do
will you ever me maybe there was um
maybe like that uh the initial red glowy
stick that looked like torches room
maybe they can like oh my god
this should not be happening to an
eight-year-old boy it's like the TARDIS
but not demon TARDIS end of death you
can't act like that I didn't even know
this was a demo no that was fantastic
oh man I can't believe this that was so
cool
what do you mean old I prize loading a
game oh that was so cool I'm so into
that actually literally like how I did
this lighting it's kind of this ominous
red glow and this is whole like red rust
bloody type thing that was so cool well
done oh man and I didn't notice like any
assets that I've seen another RPG horror
games that was fantastic I love that I
wish it was the full game I thought it
was just short oh man I want to play
this you guys gotta play this for
yourself maybe they're like all these
RPG [ __ ] games they seem to have
secrets and things that I don't find
when I play through it but oh my
goodness those fantastic who's who's
going on who's a face spider who is
pumpkin head bag man I want to know
so either way hope you guys enjoy this
that was I loved it loved the story I
loved the creepypasta into it loved the
elements of just did you get out of this
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching
check the description there's a whole
bunch of RPG horror games that I played
in the past haven't forgot about corpse
party gonna play it very soon it's just
a very long game so I need to figure out
how I'm gonna break it up but anyway
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video bye-bye
this is a looping laughing